what happens to rappers dude what are
rappers doing you know what I'm saying
Rick Ross has a bunker hey dude I know
you know we knew right even though we
didn't know we knew that was the next
thing for him for sure it's going down
y'all know how I love real estate and I
usually like to Bild and go
up we going underground now one time for
all my Doomsday Preppers Elon mus I see
I saw your ground plans I'm impressed
but guess what he always sounds like he
just got over a sinus infection what my
bunker going to have a
garage my bunker going to have wings my
bunker going to have wings like like
buffalo wings or like it's going to fly
cuz honestly neither of those things are
important your Bonker should stay
underground maybe he means he's going to
have a plane go into the bunker a garage
with a plane this guy Le Luther um huh
yeah breaking ground huge excavations
you got to have your
fluids
what a [__] dude huge excavations you
got to have your
fluids dude huge
excavations that's
amazing I got a water maker a some NE a
machine that makes water out of
H2O water is
H2O
ow I got a water maker we got our canned
goods not impressive
dude so if you thinking the brothers
ain't ready we
ready
dude we breaking ground you know this
guy's so so bored there's you can't
every time you look at a a Rick
Ross video you're like oh well dude
you're
bored that's it that's what it is we're
breaking
ground I'm Excavating just learned it
just learned the word somebody said used
the word Excavating this is exactly what
happened to Rick Ross somebody used the
word Excavating in a sentence and he
said what's that and they said it's like
Excavating it's like when you when you
like take out a bunch of uh ground you
know what it is it's like if you want to
make a bunker you go into the ground and
you excavate excavate the the ground to
make the bunker and that was what made
him want to do a bunker I guarantee it
dude I
promise no doubt dude you said what
could it have
wings that's what he did and it were
like wings like buffalo
wings could you have a garage in it uh
yeah you can have a garage in the bunker
as long as the ramp goes
down I usually build up though you could
build
down it's going down y'all know how I
love real estate and I usually like to
build and go up
build we going underground now one time
for all my Doomsday Preppers honestly
the conversation about the word excavate
excavation happened four minutes before
this he recorded this and then he
decided and now he's going to do it mus
I see you I saw your ground plant I'm
impressed but guess what my bunker going
to have a
garage my bunker going to have
wings huh didn't hear
himself uh
unbelievable but congratulations dude
because he's basically a scientist if he
can make uh water at H2O that's amazing
dude he's he's very Christlike Rick Ross
has a a plane engine coffee table so
it's like I got to keep working until I
can get a plane engine coffee table
table I wonder how much whatever it is
what it is I just had my table delivered
been waiting on this a long time guess
what I did this is my amazing brunch
area so lonely this is my amazing brunch
area dude even having a brunch area is
crazy if you have a brunch
area and you have no wife that's fine
you suck dicks and that's all good but
you do that absolutely right but guess
what we did I bought a from a 757
airliner that's right in Airplane a
757 airliner had the blades polished had
the lights inserted I could change the
lights any color I want to had the
tabletop the top glass cut this is
custom this is a Ricky Ros
customization Ricky Ros request in this
brunch area just for enjoying the finest
spirits of course Luke B dude it sound
his mouth sounds so juicy it's making me
thirsty is that
weird just has so much drool coming out
of it McQueen bamboo Von right in front
of my one of my favorite fish tanks that
you can see on both sides of the wall
and wow we pulled it off shout out to my
team it's amazing I'm happy I'm F to
have me a glass of uh bum boo of course
I'm going have a glass of bumo dude him
just sitting drinking the cream like
alcohol on his D me if you want to know
how much I spent on this you know salute
to the team for making this happen dude
I'm gonna I'm gonna ask him how much he
did I'm gonna ask him I'm gonna DM him
right now I'm gonna DM Rick Ross right
now how much did you spend on the on the
um on the uh what what do I say on
the um Rich
Forever how much did you spend I'm going
to do a voice note actually here yo yo
I've just C I honestly I honestly want
to know how much you spent on uh the
airline table or the the the air engine
table you said dmu and I think it's like
it's got to be a lot of money
right but I mean it's nothing to you but
still anyway let me know if if you said
dmu
ask that's the first time I ever reached
out to Rick Ross so there we go we'll
get back to you there uh on that and
we'll let you know how much he spent on
his airline coffee table it's by the way
crazy that you can just be anyone huh
dude I'd be so mad if I was Rick Ross
and Chris ayia sent me a voice note I'd
be angry I'd hire a hitman you know like
that's so that is yeah that's I regret
that I did it but I'm not going to
unsend it that's just wild